en qué situación concreta se han
encontrado en el país con los turistas
rusos y ucranianos y porque había un
número tan alto de turistas en estas
fechas
bueno buenas noches primero y gracias
por la invitación y la realidad es que
europa del este se ha convertido en una
fuente importante como países emisores
de turistas a nuestro país recibimos
casi 50.000 mensual en los últimos meses
y era el número natural en el ritmo de
visitas que tenemos de los visitantes
tanto rusos como ucranianos
y en este caso ante la lamentable
situación hemos tratado junto con el
touroperador de organizar su retorno a
casa en el caso de los rusos y los
ucranianos a los diferentes lugares
donde han deseado realizar su retiro hay
algunos que obviamente han preferido
quedarse en el país ya con un estatus
migratorio más permanente y con la
facilidad de que ha dado la autoridad
dominicana en facilidades o en
establecimientos que han decidido
utilizar a más largo plazo usted está
hablando de que algunos han sido
repatriados a países donde ellos han
pedido ser llevados ha habido algún tipo
de problema en este punto concreto
porque el espacio aéreo ruso está
cerrado y han recibido algún tipo de
ayuda internacional
por el momento nosotros hemos recibido
un gesto solidario del touroperador
internacional tui y colaboración del
touroperador internacional annex y
obviamente las propiedades turísticas
las empresas internacionales han
colaborado con extensiones del estadía a
su costo el gobierno dominicano también
ha colaborado
asumiendo parte de los costos de estadía
nos hemos trasladado la mayoría de los
ucranianos los hemos concentrado en la
ciudad de puerto plata a partir del día
de hoy para facilitar los vuelos de
retorno que hemos recibido de parte del
touroperador pero ha habido mucha ayuda
en sentido de facilidad de transporte de
parte de los sindicatos de transporte
han colaborado donando su la
transportación y nosotros hemos
permanecido con los huéspedes dentro de
los hoteles en el caso de que se haya
suspendido que haya pasado su estadía
hemos extendido su estadía en algunos
casos a nuestro costo en otro a su
propio costo
pero muchos también han decidido por su
propio medio retornar tenían donde
retornar eeuu a otro lugar en europa esa
ha sido la situación en este momento de
la guerra se está denunciando que en
ciertos puntos del mundo está empezando
a sentirse cierta xenofobia contra
ciudadanos rusos ha habido algún tipo de
problema en su país y han tenido algún
tipo de avión en el que haya habido
ciudadanos rusos y ucranianos juntos ha
habido algún tipo de problema también en
este sentido o todo ha sido fácil no por
el momento nosotros no hemos visto
ningún ningún hecho de estas naturales
presentarse en nuestro país
y tenemos cifras de que en torno a 9.000
turistas rusos han sido ya evacuados nos
puede dar alguna cifra cifra concreta y
qué va a pasar ahora con los que quedan
todavía en el país bueno el programa de
retorno continúa hasta anoche seguía
normal de determinar el retorno lo
debemos determinar en unos 5 días
adicionales si permiten los vuelos en el
caso de los ucranianos en los vuelos que
están programados deberían al final de
esta semana los que van a salir de
república dominicana ya deberían de
estar en los lugares de europa américa
que han decidido ir ya sea por sus
propios medios o asistido por la
facilidad de que se han dado a través de
turoperadores y del gobierno dominicano